meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
seien sie alle sehr herzlich begrüßt und
willkommen geheißen
zum traditionellen konzert der
militärmusik niederösterreich heuer
einmal anders als live stream
ich begrüße sie hier im haus der musik
in der marktgemeinde grafenwörth unter
einhaltung der drei regeln 3g regeln
findet das konzert hier heute statt und
mein name ist thomas schweiger ich darf
sie heute durch diesen live stream
begleiten
im märz 2020 kurzfristig wegen der auch
auf österreich überschwappen corona
pandemie abgesagt war der live stream
eigentlich schon im april dieses jahres
geplant und musste abermals verschoben
werden und so freuen wir uns ganz
besonders dass sie heute zu hause oder
unterwegs gemeinsam mit uns diesen abend
verbringen vielleicht mit einem gläschen
bier einem abhole gespritzt oder einem
gläschen wein die füße vielleicht sogar
im pool entspannt und gemütlich zu hause
mit ihren lieben dieser livestream wird
übrigens auch weiter auf der homepage
der militärmusik für sie verfügbar
bleiben das heißt sie können dieses
konzert oder teile des konzertes gerne
nachhören
wir hoffen auch dass wir nicht nur
unsere niederösterreichischen freunde im
livestream begrüßen dürfen sondern
vielleicht auch viele zuhörer über die
landesgrenzen hinaus begrüßen dürfen und
zu freunden der blasmusik
niederösterreich machen werden
zu beginn hören sie nun eine
grußbotschaft unserer frau
bundesministerin magistra klaudia tanner
des einzelnen in der dort wo die
freiheit des anderen beginnt er hatte
zuseherinnen und zuseher
obwohl dieses zitat des deutschen
philosophen immanuel kant knapp 250
jahre alt ist hat es genau heute in
dieser herausfordernden zeit seit dem
bestehen der zweiten republik wohl
nichts an bedeutung verloren
die eindämmung der pandemie mit test
straßen einen nationalen impfplan das
ist ein kraftakt aller im einsatz
stehende blaulichtorganisationen
freiwilligen und selbstverständlich des
österreichischen bundesheer ist um zu
einem normalen alltag wieder
zurückkehren zu können werden noch viele
anstrengungen in den nächsten wochen
monaten auf uns alle zukommen
es werden vielfältig sein mühsam
herausfordernd und uns an die
persönlichen grenzen bringen
es wird nötig sein auch weiterhin die
eigenen bedürfnisse hintanzustellen um
die sicherheit und gesundheitlich
unversehrtheit aller menschen in unserer
gesellschaft sicherzustellen heißt aber
auch dass diese einschränkungen die
ausnahmslos alle von uns betreffen
lohnend sein werden
ich bin überzeugt davon dass die
republik österreich die krise in europa
als vorreiterin hinter sich lassen wird
in wirtschaftlicher sozialer und
gesundheitlicher hinsicht da wir in
allen diesen bereichen durch
vorausschauende maßnahmen abgesichert
sind bei denen es nun gilt sie bis zum
ende der pandemie durchzuhalten
genau dieses durchhaltevermögen sehr
geehrte damen und herren das zeigen die
soldatinnen und soldaten des
österreichischen bundesheeres seit
geraumer zeit täglich in den
verschiedensten aufgaben und funktionen
dafür möchte ich mich heute recht
herzlich bei allen soldatinnen und
soldaten sowie ein zivilbediensteten
bedanken
wie vielfältig die einsatzmöglichkeiten
und die belastbarkeit der soldatinnen
und soldaten sind das zeigt dieses
heutige konzert der militärmusik
niederösterreich als vorzeige
blasorchester des militärkommandos steht
sie heute als vorreiterin ganz im
mittelpunkt dieses live
bei mehreren einsätzen im vergangenen
sowie im heurigen jahr standen die
jungen musikerinnen und musiker im
brennpunkt des geschehens und
überzeugten durch professionelles
auftreten
davon konnte ich mich selbst an vielen
orten vergewissern
darüber hinaus überzeugt dieses
orchester gleichzeitig durch
musikalische qualität die die mitglieder
zusätzlich zu ihrem dienst als soldat in
als soldat einbringen
während der pandemie stammen alle neuen
militärmusiker im assistenzeinsatz das
heißt an den grenzen den test straßen
oder im kontext sehen
dies zeigt eindeutig von der qualität
der militärischen ausbildung innerhalb
der musiker und deren universelle
einsetzbarkeit dass dieses projekt das
erste online konzert einer militärmusik
in österreich seit ausbruch der pandemie
zusätzlich neben den soeben aufgezählten
aufgaben in teils monatelangen
vorbereitungen und unter einhaltung
aller komik 19 auflagen stattfinden kann
ist zum großteil dem engagement der
musikerinnen und musiker zu verdanken
diese haben keine mühen gescheut um
ihnen in dieser turbulenten zeit ein
stückchen normalität in ihr wohnzimmer
zu bringen und damit zu beweisen dass
die musiken als waffengattung im
bundesheer nicht nur einen wichtigen
beitrag zum gelingen militärischer
einsätze leisten sondern auch für das
wohl das sälen mit höchsten
musikalischen ansprüchen verantwortlich
zeichnen
quasi eine rundumversorgung wie sie nur
das österreichische bundesheer in der
lage ist zu leisten unter militär
kapellmeister oberstleutnant radio
obendrauf werden sie die musiker in
diesem konzert musikalisch in eine welt
voll harmonie aber auch ohrenbetäubender
überraschungen führen
bei den keiner ihre sinne zu kurz kommen
wird dies kann ich aus dem bereits
gewonnen
erfahrungen vergangener konzerte nur
bestätigen
genießen sie mit uns die folgenden
minuten dieses außergewöhnlichen
klangkörpers ganz im sinne von musik
sagt mehr als tausend worte bleiben sie
gesund halten sie durch sie können sich
auf die soldatinnen und soldaten des
bundesheeres verlassen
einen schönen abend und ein
unvergessliches konzert darf ich ihnen
im namen des österreichischen
bundesheeres sowie der musikerinnen und
musiker der militärmusik
niederösterreich wünschen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
alfred riedl marsch von adolf obendrauf
und weiter schwanzer hat die
militärmusik niederösterreich unter der
leitung von militär kapellmeister oberst
magister adolf obendrauf dieses konzert
hier eröffnet wir begrüßen sie zum live
stream zum konzert der militärmusik
niederösterreich im haus der musik in
grafenwörth die militärmusik
niederösterreich freut sie sie erstmals
wieder zu einem konzert zwar online aber
doch wieder begrüßen zu dürfen das erste
konzert seit dem abgesagten
frühjahrskonzert im jahr 2020
ich darf nun den hausherrn und so quasi
einziger zuhörer heute abend hier in den
saal im bürgermeister der marktgemeinde
grafenwörth und gemeindebund präsidenten
magister alfred riedl zu mir bitten um
sie mich als sie um ihre grußworte
bieten
grüß gott vorweg einmal danke und
herzlich willkommen im haus der musik
liebe musikerinnen und musiker hier in
graphen wird ja liebe zuseherinnen und
zuseher wie haben wir das uns
gewünschten und wir haben wir das ja
sein das internet als bühne ist
vielleicht noch nicht das ergebnis was
wir gerne erleben würden aber auf dem
weg in die normalität ist es eine
wunderbare chance unseren jungen
musikerinnen und musikern wieder das
erlebnis zu gewähren was sie sich so
sehnlichst wünschen ich sage das auch
ganz besonders deswegen weil ich in den
musikschulen in dieses landes oft und
oft so gehört habe wie sie sich sehnen
nach einem gemeinsamen spiel und
gestatten sie mir auch gleich ein großes
danke zu sagen
der kapellmeister und der
militärkommando niederösterreich dass
unsere jungen talente in unserem land
eine so hervorragende bühne und eine so
großartige sozusagen kapelle miterleben
und mitgestalten dürfen dass sie sich in
ihren talenten einfach entwickeln können
diese zusammenarbeit
zwischen den österreichischen und
österreichischen städten und gemeinden
und der militärmusik ist etwas ganz was
besonderes und dafür darf ich an dieser
stelle auch ein herzliches danke sagen
in diesem sinne wünsche ich ihnen allen
einen wunderschönen abend wir freuen uns
einfach weder das gemeinsame spiel hören
zu dürfen und ich wünsche ihnen ein tor
tor tor für einen tollen konzertabend
vielen dank herr präsident für ihre
worte ja weiter geht es im programm
ludwig van beethoven ist der korona
bedingt verhinderte jahres regent des
jahres 2020 und so würdigt die
militärmusik niederösterreich den aus
bonn stammenden aber einen großteil
seiner lebensjahre in österreich zu
bringen den komponisten der wiener
klassik im heutigen konzert entstanden
in der zeit der napoleonischen besetzung
von teilen österreichs und geprägt vom
gedanken an die freiheit komponierte
beethoven im auftrag des wiener
burgtheaters eine schauspielmusik zu
goethes trauerspiel egmont aus dieser
schauspiel musik hören sie nun die
overtüre mit den tempo bezeichnungen
sostenuto man on top und allegro
[Musik]
ludwig van beethoven verbrachte viele
sommermonate in niederösterreich die
meisten davon zur sommerfrische und zur
kur in baden bei wien den herbst 1826
verbrachte er im nächsten dorf bei krems
nicht unweit von grafenwörth wir hören
nun die grußbotschaft unserer
landeshauptfrau magistra johanna
mikl-leitner geschätzte damen und herren
die militärmusik niederösterreich ist
wichtiger kulturträger und bindeglied
zwischen unseren landsleuten und ihren
soldaten und soldatinnen ein wichtiger
kulturträger der uns alle mit
musikalischen klängen immer wieder aufs
neue fasziniert und eine unglaublich
reiche und schöne tradition hat denn die
wurzeln reichen über 300 jahre auf die
musikkapellen des kuk
infanterieregiments zurück über 200
auftritte im jahr im mietvertrag
sprechen für die musikalische exzellenz
und reiche tradition der militärmusik
die militärmusik die seit august 2011
unter der erfolgreichen leitung von
oberstleutnant adolf um darf steht im
namen der niederösterreicherin
niederösterreich danke ich ihnen allen
für die musikalische bereicherung in
unserem land und vor allem für die
hervorragende zusammenarbeit ihnen ein
darf ich nun einen traumhaft schönen
abend mit der militärmusik
niederösterreich wünschen alles gute und
gute unterhaltung
die militärmusik niederösterreich hat
die vergangenen monate unter anderem
dazu benützt für den verlag orchestral
art referenz aufnahmen zeitgenössische
kompositionen für symphonisches
blasorchester aufzunehmen darunter auch
das folgende werk eine rhapsodie für
sinfonisches blasorchester von helmut
kohl
mit dem titel tabula rasa mit dem
lateinischen begriff tabula rasa wird
ursprünglich das löschen einer
vorgeschriebenen schiefertafel
bezeichnet vergessen sie all das
unerwartete das schlechte und mühsame
löschen wir so weit wie möglich das
ungemach der vergangenen monate löschen
wir
die tafel reißen wir das vorgeschriebene
kalenderblatt der schwierigen monate ab
und beschreiben wir das noch
unbeschriebene blatt einer besseren
zukunft neu jeder einzelne von uns kann
diese zukunft mitgestalten machen wir
gemeinsam mit der militärmusik
niederösterreich tabula rasa
[Musik]
ein
liebe zuschauer und zuhörerinnen nun
wird es extrem und noch einmal steht
ludwig van beethoven im zentrum des
konzertes beethoven selbst guide ja
nicht gerade als einfacher mensch wohl
auch wegen seiner früh einsetzenden
schwerhörigkeit im gleichen dorf soll er
der grotte musikant oder der närrische
und tierischer bruder von tätigen herrn
genannt worden seien
der kongeniale blasmusik komponist
johann de meij nimmt einige bekannte
werke beethovens und schlüpft in die
rolle eines fleischhauers und eines
haben koches gleichermaßen der beethoven
muss obere zerlegt zerhackt und viele
tiere manche teile verwurstet manches
ein kochen lässt anderes wiederum
streckt und das ganze zu einer
unerwarteten menüfolge genialer
leckerbissen schichtet schlichtet und
formt er wird etwa der zweite satz des
klavierkonzertes nummer fünf als gruß
aus der küche vorangestellt dem kredenzt
den zuhörer dann auch schon mal
unkonventionell einen musikalischen
burger mit vier symphonischen lagen oder
lässt eine kleine panda aufmarschieren
die ihr eigenes süppchen kochen darf
und dann gilt es für den genießer die
zutaten und gewürze herauszuschmecken da
ein wenig die pastorale dort die erika
im mondschein eine sonate für elise oder
doch der egmont mit dem türkischen
marsch ihr final die ode an die freude
erklingt seid umschlungen millionen
melodien und das aus nur zwölf tönen
jedenfalls ein werk auf höchstem niveau
genüsse
im feinsten in einem hauben menü aller
höchster musikalischer klasse für das
der mumie wohl eine sechste haube dem
komponisten verleihen müsste kurz gesagt
extrem extreme beethoven
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte zuschauerinnen und zuhörer
während sich die musikerinnen und
musiker der militärmusik
niederösterreich nun in einer etwa 25
minütige pause begeben können sie
einblicke in den alltag der militärmusik
niederösterreich gewinnen
wir danken dem orf niederösterreich der
die folgende tv dokumentation aus der
reihe unterwegs in österreich aus dem
jahr 20 18 zur ausstrahlung im rahmen
des heutigen live streams kostenlos zur
verfügung gestellt hat sie blicken nun
mitgestalter werner fetz und den beiden
kameramännern andreas kautzmann und
helmut muthenthaler hinter die kulissen
der militärmusik niederösterreich
erleben die proben und ausbildungsarbeit
bis hin zu konzerten und einem auftritt
beim militärmusikfestival am roten platz
in moskau
[Musik]
die militärmusik niederösterreich mehr
als 60 jahre musikalische tradition mit
wechselvoller geschichte
auch wer hier mit marschiert hat schon
einen längeren weg hinter sich
ein weg der für janko die bereiter bei
der stellungs kommission der sogenannten
musterung beginnt der gelernte
maschinenbauer und betriebselektriker
hat klare vorstellungen
sie haben sich ja bereits eingetragen
bei denen einberufung wünschen zur
militärmusik ist das nach wie vor
gewohnt weil deswegen neben der
gesundheitlichen eignung muss auch das
musikalische können entsprechen wer zur
militärmusik will uns vor spielen wie
die ausgebildete volksschullehrerin
caroline binder
[Musik]
die dienstzeit der militärmusiker
beträgt 13 monate die der musikerinnen
zwölf monate und beginnt immer im august
mit einer allgemeinen basisausbildung
wie sie dort ich schaue mir das einfach
in der 100
diese richtung gefunden jawohl gefunden
die die es zur militärmusik schaffen
haben die musik meist schon in die wiege
gelegt bekommen
die bin schon seit die senior bin weil
er bei einer musikkapelle in der
ortschaft in wartberg und genau und mein
papa ist kapellmeister und der hat das
rundschreiben immer halten dass leute
gesucht werden und darum sofort sagt
eigentlich hört er heute dann sofort
mitmachen wie wenn in einer familie von
musikanten geworden als jüngstes kind
vor dem aber ich werde mir klar dass
jahren musikanten werden wer hat ich
habe dann das weiter friedlich
zusammengelebt lernen angefangen und bin
damit aufgehört weil die werkvolkkapelle
pille weg zur kammermusik schon die
ausbildung weiter gemacht und bin dann
irgendwie papa mit dieser musik
überhaupt nicht darüber denkt das ist
auch für lässt sich ganz cool auf reifen
wir waren also darüber denkt das passt
perfekt zu mir
an die 300 einsätze hat die militärmusik
niederösterreich im jahr 2017 absolviert
die österreichische militär musik ist
geprägt von der monarchie her also in
der monarchie war die hochblüte tja
militärmusik und dazu über 100 regiments
musik damals gegeben
geprägt ist diese militärmusik von den
vielen völkern die wir hatten also dass
amerikanische und deutsche militärische
sind erst rating tempo und die
österreichische militär musik ist
geprägt von den vielen völkern vor allem
ungarn und das zeichnet uns aus wir
haben auch märsche die natürlich zu
marschieren bestens geeignet sind aber
auch melodie haben wunderschöne melodie
haben
[Musik]
damit die militärmusik so klingt wie sie
klingt und die auftritte so aussehen
wird intensiv geübt bei den sogenannten
registerproben etwas spielen die
instrumentengruppen einzeln hier haben
die register führer das kommando
in der gesamtprobe dann der
kapellmeister
dank ja anfangen nicht immer
gleichzeitig an diesen teppich hörner
dieses blech legen sehr gut die basis
sind super alle anderen nicht zu früh
kommt man mit dem ersten ton auch mal
das treffen gut stimmten auch anja am
papa wir haben die militärischen
hierarchien hier sehr wohl also wir sind
untereinander nicht bedurft der
kapellmeister ist üblicherweise bei sie
mit seinen mitarbeitern mit seiner
musikern auch die register führer als
und offiziere sind passé aber diese
militärische hierarchie ist aus meiner
sicht schon notwendig muss einen
gewissen respekt abstand haben aber auf
der anderen seite die musik lebt er dann
nur weil man doch etwas lockerer
miteinander umgeht und wie es aussieht
wenn locker und doch militärisch präzise
gespielt wird zeigen die
österreichischen militär musikkapellen
in ihren showvorführungen
im sommer 2017 sind in oberwart alle
neuen militär musikkapellen
zusammengetroffen
trotz der großen zahl an auftritten
probt die militärmusik niederösterreich
für derartige vorführungen in jeder
freien minute in der kaserne in sankt
pölten
[Musik]
zelten richtung beim marschieren
was sagt das gegenüberliegende
[Musik]
die militärmusik versteht sich aber
nicht nur als orchester im eigenen
notenarchiv wird auch das musikalische
kultur gut bewahrt und weitergetragen
also notenblätter und es keinerlei
aussagen verbessern einige tonnen
wahrscheinlich kann er so anders war
laufende nummern über 4000 haben das
beinhaltet aber nicht nur für bronze
gestern stück ist nach für ensembles
beziehungsweise instrumenten schön in
der pflege ist es ganz wichtig dass die
noten so gehandhabt werden
beziehungsweise aktiviert werden dass er
für die nächste generation download zur
verfügung stehen die militärmusik
niederösterreich ist 1957 in haren im
waldviertel entstanden hat also 2017 den
sechzigsten geburtstag gefeiert seit
1964 ist man in sankt pölten stationiert
die wurzeln lassen sich aber bis ins
jahr 1715 zurückverfolgen
die hauptaufgaben prenzel haben sich
nicht großartig verändert damals war
vielleicht dass man die musik mit zum
einsatz genommen hat spricht zum krieg
das hat sich natürlich verändert
die musik die militärmusik wurde
eigentlich verwendet um den
gleichschritt der truppe zu halten um
signale wurden verwendet um militärische
signale zum angriff zu blasen und so
weiter aber auch natürlich die truppe zu
belustigen zwischen den kämpfen musste
die truppe auch belustigt werden und
dafür war die militärmusik da das ist
heute natürlich schon anders aber die
werbung und das aushängeschild aus
meiner sicht ist geblieben wir maschinen
vor der truppe die druck der mann steht
hinter uns nach und wir sind werbeträger
des bundesheeres und des militärs ein
werbeträger jährigen jüngster
vergangenheit durch schwierige zeiten
gegangen ist eine reform hatte
ursprünglich die reduktion auf vier
kapellen für ganz österreich später dann
eine verkleinerung der militärmusik von
knapp 50 auf jeweils 20 musiker pro
bundesland vorgesehen
die aufregung war enorm mit der
reduktion wäre es nicht mehr möglich die
großen traditionsmesse oder den
zapfenstreich zu spielen so die kritik
damals die reduktion wurde schließlich
zurückgenommen
ich habe keinen chan ist der nutzen es
ist ein imageträger
es ist die verbindung zur kultur zur
blasmusik und ich glaube wir hatten zeit
nimmt und es ja wo wir kein geld hatten
wohl massiv unter druck tiert waren und
da stand alles zur diskussion
aberglaube das fällt jetzt unter
geschichte das ist jetzt vorbei und es
geht es darum dass in die zukunft
schauen
musik lahr hat eine kulturelle aufgabe
dazu zählt auch die militärmusik dass
das dass das beibehalten wird jede
militärmusik in den bundesländern hat
eine spezifische aufgabe und diese
tradition weiter zu erhalten
[Musik]
ruhig ist es bei der militärmusik
eigentlich nur sehr selten neben den
unterkunftsräumen stehenden musikerinnen
und musikern in der resser kaserne auch
zahlreiche proberäume zur verfügung
[Musik]
auch die instrumente müssen entsprechend
versorgt und gepflegt werden um die
uniformen und damit um einen
wesentlichen punkt des
erscheinungsbildes kümmert sich mit
jahrzehnten an erfahrung günter müller
und wenn dann wirklich einmal zeit
bleibt dann zeigt sich dass die
musikerinnen und musiker auch ohne
instrumente gut harmonieren noch dienst
immer in welcher freizeitaktivitäten
natürlich auch irgendwo umsetzen und
aber trotzdem über das wochenende hinaus
zb also auf jeden fall eine
eingeschworene gruppe die zeit bei der
militärmusik schmiedet zusammen
kein nachteil bei den vielen stunden die
man gemeinsam unterwegs ist etwa zu den
angelogen
[Musik]
und sein volk zu schützen und sein volk
zu schützen
[Musik]
ein ganz besonderer auftritt ist in die
geschichte der militärmusik
niederösterreich eingegangen das
gastspiel 1977 im film little night
music das lächeln einer sommernacht mit
liz taylor für den auch in
niederösterreich gedreht wurde aber eine
musik benötigt war die militärmusik
ankam uniformen gesteckt worden
dann ist eigentlich kontrolliert worden
die militärmusik gespielt leider war für
damalige verhältnisse so gut gespielt
lobt versuchte man halt und höher zu
spielen dann war er zu schlecht dann hat
man sich irgendwann kommt dies gerne ein
drittel der knapp 50 personen starken
militärmusik sind kadersoldaten der rest
grundwehrdiener und militärpersonen auf
zeit und immer mehr frauen spiel mit der
einzige unterschied also bei den
aufnahmeprüfungen und sonst muss ich
sagen habe das eigentlich gleichermaßen
erfahren also ab und ausbildung her und
den umgang mit der ausbilder
ich habe da kein unterschied also bei
mir war es nur von mir reden
also ich habe genauso schlechte tag
erlebt sowie gute aus der zeit der
ausbildung müssen ist im prinzip einig
sie wert findet und man lernt auch
selber über sich selber recht für kinder
weil sie sagen mir das vor ich bin so
gerne bei der militärmusik gibt es da
dass dauernd ich bin immer spüren es ist
einfach so lange mit seinem hobby geld
verdienen kann und war mal sein hobby
zum beruf machen kann
das ist echt leid
[Musik]
die aktiven und ehemaligen
militärmusiker bilden ein wesentliches
rückgrat des blasmusik wesens insgesamt
für unsere musikkapellen unsere mehr als
500 musikkapelle niederösterreich
natürlich eine kaderschmiede ca 2000
musikantinnen und musikanten von den
insgesamt 25.000 in niederösterreich
waren in den letzten jahrzehnten in dem
militär musikkapellen und viele von
ihnen haben auch führende positionen
dann in ihren vereinen übernommen
als kapellmeister stimmführer ausbildner
oder auch als als ob mann oder frau
und daher sind diese absolventen der
militärmusik hier in führungspositionen
dann auch sehr oft in den vereinen
vertreten
die militärmusik gibt es übrigens nicht
nur in dieser formation kleinere
formationen treten als quartett oder
quintett bei veranstaltungen als big
band oder auch tanzorchester auf etwa
hier beim bauernbund bei
[Musik]
auch auf eine ganze reihe von
auslandseinsätzen kann die militärmusik
niederösterreich mittlerweile
zurückblicken einer der höhepunkte der
auftritt bei der internationalen
soldatenwallfahrt in lohr den frankreich
im jahr 2017
[Musik]
im august 2017 hat die militärmusik
niederösterreich österreich bei einem
musik treffen auf dem roten platz in
moskau vertreten
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ein weiterer höhepunkt unter den vielen
auftritten ist das alljährliche
frühjahrskonzert für das intensiv
geprobt wird
dabei will man mit einem anspruchsvollen
programm
jahr für jahr zeigen dass die
militärmusik weiter mehr spielt als
traditionsmarke ein breites repertoire
aus sinfonischer und auch moderner
blasmusik wird geboten
[Musik]
gerade die militärmusik die als
berufsorchester niederösterreich wird
hat sich zum ziel genommen alles anderes
abzudecken und hier vor allem auch die
symphonische blasmusik der von der
blaskapelle draußen auch gespielt wird
und es gibt da sehr gute
niederösterreichische komponisten junge
komponisten die neue musik schreiben und
da spielen wir natürlich gerne auch
diese literatur das beginnt wie gesagt
von der marschmusik die unsere
traditionelle musik ist aber es geht bis
zur symphonischen blasmusik schon nach
dem einspielen im festspielhaus st
briten sind nervosität und vorfreude
gleichermaßen groß dass wir druckvoll
und dann gäbe es das gibt dass jeder
seine leistung bringt da war selber
macht wir sind natürlich eindruck
gewesen wie es ist ich habe vier oder
fünf emmys erst einmal versuchen will
air konzert zu spielen gibt obendrein
sicher paar monate jetzt seite doppeln
und jetzt quasi wirklich schon alles
muss endlich dann präsentieren ak
[Musik]
für vivaldis trompetenkonzert kehrt ein
ehemaliger militärmusiker als gastsolist
zurück der mittlerweile an der volksoper
beim elbphilharmonie orchester und auch
beim radio symphonieorchester mitspielt
[Musik]
es hat schon sehr große parallelen man
muss sagen man muss einfach im orchester
oder bei der militärmusik zu jeder zeit
einfach an punktspielen man muss
abliefern und durch die ganzen
unzähligen zapfenstreich was wir
gespielt haben haben wir das natürlich
gut üben können weil jetzt gilt und
jetzt muss passen und so ist ein profi
orchester genauso
auch die solisten aus der militärmusik
begeistern an diesem abend etwa mit
einem schwungvollen medley aus den hits
von udo jürgens
[Musik]
caroline binder wie bei der militärmusik
bleiben jakob dippel reiter wird wieder
in seinen beruf zurückkehren
die zeit bei der militärmusik sagen sie
schon jetzt wird bleiben und sie
musikalisch prägen es ist ein
kameradschaften und leonskaja uns das
ist sicher glaube ich länger man sich
danach aber wieder trifft und reden kann
was er gerade viel spaß gehabt hat man
sei das einzige berufs blasorchester des
landes sagt kapellmeister obendrauf
immer wieder und lege die latte deshalb
besonders um die musikerinnen und
musiker der militärmusik überspringen
sie gerne täglich und b3 sind sie sind
vollblutmusiker in uniform
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das publikum zu hause oder unterwegs an
den unterschiedlichsten endgeräten wir
sind wieder zurück im haus der musik in
grafenwörth zum konzert der militärmusik
niederösterreich heute im live stream
das eröffnungsstück des zweiten
programmteils kann jetzt urlaubsfreude
bei ihnen decken geht es doch in einem
technisch herausforderten
klarinettenkonzert mit temperamentvollen
flamenco klängen nach spanien
der preisgekrönte film komponist ost
cannavaro selbst ausgebildeter
klarinettist hat sein zweites konzert
für klarinette und symphonieorchester
auch für blasorchester transkribiert es
ist der militärmusik niederösterreich
nun eine ganz besondere ehre als solist
den aus der steiermark stammenden
klarinettisten stefan mörz präsentieren
zu dürfen
stefan mörz studierte an der universität
für musik und darstellende kunst in wien
und ist seit der saison 2015/16
soloklarinettist des deutschen
symphonie-orchesters berlin
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die neuen militär musikkapellen in
österreich werden unter anderem vom
verein wiederkehr musikfreunde
österreich unterstützt sie hören jetzt
die an ob man wolfram baldauf mit seiner
grußbotschaft die militärmusik mit über
500 jährige tradition sind neben den
wiener philharmonikern und den wiener
sängerknaben die drähte unverzichtbare
säule des musik landes österreich wir
vom förderverein müller der musikfreunde
österreich stehen für die erhaltung
aller neuen militärmusik dem vorjahr
spielstärke ein wenn sie das auch
unterstützen wollen bitte melden sie
sich über die website militär
musikfreunde punkt at an die
militärmusik niederösterreich ist durch
dieses online konzert wieder präsent und
darüber freuen wir uns sehr
und als man das militär musikfreunde
vereines grüße ich die soldaten
musikantinnen und soldaten musikanten
sehr herzlich und wünschte weiterhin
viel erfolg
nach der klarinette konzertiert jetzt
gleich mit der flöte ein weiteres
holzblasinstrument auch ein instrument
das in der militärmusik gesucht ist die
flöte spielt in den höchsten tönen
coverage und agil
sie verkörpert oft singende vögel wird
war nachtigallen auch hirtenmusik ist
ihr metier und wenn die flöte manchmal
als mücke ausgewachsenen elefanten um
den rüssel schweren so ist es in der
zeit einer pandemie wohl der rüssel
eines kleinen baby elefanten
jedenfalls wird es mit flöten als
soloinstrument immer virtuos und so
jetzt auch im dritten satz finale mit
der tempo bezeichnung moderator aus dem
concerto in d dur für flöte und
orchester von karl heinrich reinecke
solistin auf der flöte ist maria fahren
der wir an dieser stelle für den
abschluss ihres diplomstudiums im fach
instrumental und gesangspädagogik
hauptfach flöte am richard wagner
konservatorium in wien alles gute
wünschen sie hat ihre letzte prüfung
diese woche freuen sie sich nun auf das
stück finale aus dem concerto in d dur
für flöte und orchester von karl
heinrich reinecke mit der solistin maria
fan-gruppe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die militärmusiker kapellen sind dem
militärkommando des jeweiligen
bundeslandes zugeordnet die militärische
grundausbildung der neuen militär
musikerinnen und militärmusiker findet
für die militärmusik niederösterreich in
st pölten statt
im bedarfsfall kann die militärmusik
auch zu nicht musikalischen einsätzen
herangezogen werden so würde die
militärmusik niederösterreich während
der pandemie führt grenzkontrollen als
assistenz im postverteilzentrum
hagenbrunn oder im kontakt racing für
das land niederösterreich eingesetzt sie
sehen nun die grußbotschaft des
militärkommandanten von niederösterreich
brigadier magister martin jaworek
geschätzt der damen und herren werte
freunde damit die der musik
niederösterreich ist nahezu ein jahr her
dass wir letztes jahr die ersten
maßnahmen zur eindämmung der krone
pandemie das konzert das bereits geplant
und ausverkauft war damit der musik
niederösterreich im festspielhaus
absagen mussten dem jahr ist ja viel
passiert mit heutigen tag sind über 500
soldaten und soldatinnen und
zivilbedienstete das militärkommando
niederösterreich im einsatz zu
unterstützen oder gesundheitsbehörde in
der ganz großen bandbreite beginnend vom
einsatz der grenze die kontaktadresse
bei den bezirkshauptmannschaften in der
info logistik bei der drive ins um den
vier verschiedene aufgaben
seit neuesten seit zwei wochen im
industrieviertel im einsatz zur
unterstützung der gesundheitsbehörden
zur eindämmung der pandemie auch heuer
kann somit das konzert in der übrigen
form nicht stattfinden
es ist für uns aber ganz wichtig dass
wir den kontakt zu ihnen geschätzte
damen und herren weiterhin halten
somit wird unter ausnutzung der moderne
technik das konzert diesmal
aufgezeichnet und es ist für sie
abrufbar
bitte genießen sie es gewünschten damit
eine schöne stunde bleiben sie gesund
bleiben sie uns wohlgesonnen und ich
hoffe dass wir uns dann wirklich wieder
live
die szenen werden vielen dank jetzt wird
es zum abschluss des konzertes der
militärmusik niederösterreich also fast
zum abschluss noch einmal richtig wild
genau genommen eigentlich gilt und
schmutzig also via dirty heute recht
wohl kaum noch jemanden auf was zur zeit
der handlung des kinofilms und der
dazugehörigen musik also noch 1963 als
umgezogen und ungewohnt
freuen sie sich nun auf johnnys mambo
she's like the wind die my baby und all
through time of my life und erleben sie
sophie eder charles francis paceman und
lukas polanski als tanzlehrer johnny
castle bei ihrem dirty dancing im
ferienresort keller menz
[Musik]
do
natürlich
sie reizen
[Musik]
next to me
juni zum meer versank
bis sie das nur zu sein
[Musik]
völlig normal
dies sei
mai
si
[Musik]
nein
zusammen
[Musik]
wir saßen
jetzt sitzen
[Musik]
filme teil
im team
[Musik]
so wie tätig
apa
[Musik]
ein paar
die schon aber unschön den juni
dessen
die menschen
[Musik]
nee
eigentlich
[Musik]
zusammen
s
[Musik]
naja
das
nein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte zuschauerinnen und zuhörer
zu hause an dieser stelle heißt es danke
zu sagen nämlich allen partnern die
schon großteils seit vielen jahren die
durchführung dieses konzertes
ermöglichen und damit die militärmusik
niederösterreich unterstützen
wir danken der landeshauptfrau von
niederösterreich dem bürgermeister der
marktgemeinde grafenwörth und der
marktgemeinde grafenwörth dem
bürgermeister und magistrat der
landeshauptstadt st pölten der
wirtschaftskammer niederösterreich der
hypo niederösterreich der kastner gruppe
der niederösterreichischen versicherung
der raiffeisenbank der uniqa
landesdirektion niederösterreich und der
weinkeller lenz moser für die
übertragung des livestreams zeichnete
die heeres bild und film stelle und
tontechnik leopold denkt verantwortlich
ganz besonders aber danken wir ihnen zu
hause
fürs dabei seien unterwegs oder
tatsächlich zu hause gemütlich auf der
couch oder wo auch immer sie diesen
konzertabend gemeinsam mit uns verbracht
haben
der livestream bleibt übrigens auf der
homepage aufrufbar und das weiterleiten
des links ist ausdrücklich erwünscht
sehr geehrte damen und herren das war
das frühjahrskonzert 20 21 der
militärmusik niederösterreich heuer
einmal anders im sommer und als
livestream hier aus dem haus der musik
in grafenwörth wir freuen uns einander
bald wieder live zu sehen
die nächste gelegenheit dazu haben sie
am 5 august um 20 uhr wenn die
militärmusik niederösterreich gemeinsam
mit der polizeimusik niederösterreich
bei den sommerfestspielen langenlois vor
dem schloss haindorf musiziert im namen
der militärmusik niederösterreich unter
der leitung von militär kapellmeister
oberst magister adolf obendrauf darf ich
mich nun von innen zu hause
verabschieden
sie hören zum abschluss natürlich wie
kann es anders sein den marsch
schlechthin der fast jedes militärmusik
konzert verabschiedet den namen lasse
ich weg den brauche ich ihnen nicht
sagen den kennen sie einen wunderschönen
abend zu hause noch mit einem gläschen
wein oder was auch immer
genießen sie hoffentlich den lauen
sommerabend ohne große gewitter ein
wiedersehen sagt ihnen moderator thomas
schwaiger
[Musik]
nein